what's going on reject nation
Greg outfit here hey case Casey Spivey
we're gonna do the whole reaction like
this so the trailer will fit perfectly
right Casey on screen rant and some
videos of the richest as well guys we're
gonna watch two TV spots for infinity
war so the first TV spot we're gonna
watch it's a short one but it has a cool
title so I was like I want to check this
out it's called spider-man kicks Thanos
oh just like how I do to my John once a
night before he goes to bed yeah I can't
sleep unless I get that right John
that's what I said so I'm talking about
[Music]
where is it whoa there's stuff to talk
about here okay I only understood like
half a okay looks like dr. strange Iron
Man and spider-man are together and then
they're bumping into the Guardians in
this scene and the guardians are with
Thor so I think this TV spot just
completely gave that away well I don't
know it's all kind of confusing it
doesn't matter what matters is if
spider-man chick that doesn't mad and
that was really cool I think that
happens in the comic actually at one
point you also get a glimpse of Iron
Man's cool ass sword here do you think
that it was my brain 'i'm sore yes
yes you and I are the exact same thing
how cool would that be right there's
also like people theorizing that like
RiRi is gonna make an appearance that
would be neat yeah but I don't really
keep up with a female character
oh-ho cuz they're just not as important
is this [ __ ] to be in America is this
spot the spot we just watched is it
gonna be in America wait we're in
America I don't know we just watched it
but it was in Spanish so I assume there
was for another market oh yeah all that
footage that we saw none of that's in
the American version right yeah that's
only in the Spanish version of the movie
yeah we're missing a lot of scenes in
American verse so that's the next one
okay all right this one's actually a
featurette that just came out from
Marvel it's called a 10-year legacy
ten years it's a short amount of time
it's a very interesting time now and boy
you don't know what's gonna happen I
know that I'm proud of it I know that
we've done a moderate single there's
something that is beyond where people's
expectations audiences were reacting to
it the way we had hoped they would was
powerful this is crazy
was that I meant working of course was
that we could build that it was as
expensive and as experiential is what
people who read comics over the years to
get I had a lot of faith and can apply
even people at Marvel you want to give
him everything you got because they're
gonna give that inconvenience this was a
whole new journey by the first Avengers
I thought oh wow I think we're onto
something here just seeing the
characters together there's something
viscerally awesome about it I think
that's why the minute Sam Jackson showed
up at the end of Iron Man 1 whether
people have read comics or not what does
that mean why is he here and then Tony
Stark
those seem like just the tiniest of
things compared to where we are now oh
yeah Nations it led us here
shifting parts and new ideas how do we
do this as a team
Seraphin is responsible for all of these
amazing actors and actions that we
brought into this I think after the
first Avengers people realized that this
was not just an ordinary movie that
there was really a lot of thought and a
lot of care and a lot of passion that's
going into each and every one of these
films wanna get some that look at the
hard work they put out sort of ideas
forward and attackee character again and
hopefully advance on that and bring
something unique to it each time it's
wonderful to be able to play this iconic
character that means so much to people
and I really have to think the
audience's for that because they
embraced my portrayal of her from the
beginning what do you think
walking shoes or sexy kick-ass in them
to ten years last photo Wow grateful
our lives are monumentally changed by
our involvement in this world
- cool shirt instrumental role in what
Marvel has done it has ten years it's
just so incredibly meaningful to us Wow
all those people in the room together
yeah these characters are mythological
characters wait you don't think so
things never happen the films have
progressed with civil war and now
infinity war we're just gonna continue
to surprise people
oh yay to bring together that got me
yeah I think it's so cool how Marvel's
been capitalizing on this whole 10-year
thing I've seen a couple of other things
where that they've cut stuff together
like yeah this is 10 years in the making
but this is probably the best one I've
seen because I love that it starts off
with three weeks before Iron Man opens
the big gamble we're taking right here
to look back at that first Iron Man you
know Robert Downey jr. was only paid
$500,000 for that movie
he now has like the smartest deal ever
because he goes for back end now he's so
rich he's like way too rich it's insane
just how hard it's ran choices come
because there was that one casting
director I think who was talking about
how when they look back at the first
couple post Avengers teases when Nick
Fury and iron man showing up back then
that was so exciting when we look at it
now like with the casting I think they
were trying to get kind of unknown
people and lock them in and and that's
what made them huge right I mean even
with Chris Hemsworth yeah they're good
people who are like huge stylist like
mega stars yeah Chris Pratt was like
someone that people really knew but this
made him like Hollywood hunk leading man
Chris Pratt right same thing with Sam
Jackson no one had ever known a Sam
Jackson before this is the kind of
commentary you guys look to cool shirt
ready what's going on but is your type
blonde hey okay thanks for letting me
know I thought you should finally learn
so you can get what you want
of this shot astrologer Hanson's ass you
just got to get that he's got to get
that in here don't you yeah oh yeah got
it
that's why they hired I'm sure only cuz
of the ass shots she's like people have
embraced my portrayal and I'm like
what's your portrayal exactly yeah
exactly I think she's correct nobody's
complaining you don't want to see her
act she's I can do she's like in a
dramatic crime scene or like come on
let's get that shot why do you gotta
sexualized everyone subscribe to the
reject nation people click that
notification Belka subscribe buttons
don't mean anything
hey you know you could do you could
check out Casey on Instagram and Twitter
hey underscore case check out our
Instagram stories where she's going to
Weiner schnitzels grabbing some chili
dogs or whatever she does during the day
okay I'm going on hikes with some tall
black guys I don't know she does screen
rat riches you cats in her videos over
there Twitter Twitter's my thing you
tweet you know that I don't ever phone I
don't ever look like my stuff on Twitter
Jon's obsessed with makes me feel sad I
was like here you go anymore Instagram
I'm there too doing some stories yeah
yeah I'm on screen rant and the richest
and all that jazz I think that's it
right
you're like enough